[Music]
[Music]
I'm the one
Super Bowl Eagles go to the Super Bowl
you want to make a better one okay okay
all right let's start the podcast by the
way Jen asked to see if we want to do a
uh uh what do you call it fantasy
football at the office maybe start and
talk about it
all right let's let's let's get right
into it okay episode 188 today's home
team myself Adam Jedediah and the
today's host of the podcast yes uh
Vinnie oshana Dan Pena you know the the
extra by the way you look you look
ridiculous how good you look you know
you look very good first of all when
yesterday they go ahead and you're gonna
be on the podcast I was like first of
all I got invited on the number one
podcast in the world business for
Spotify go I have to even though I have
no business being on here because when
you don't have an education this suit
bumped you up that's a good point right
what school did you 100 very impressive
okay so look we got a lot of topics to
go through yeah a lot of craziness uh
one I found the clip from 11 years ago
where a guy says what's going on with
the market this is from Central London
and the reaction of the host on BBC I
just want you to see how this lady
reacts when he tells the truth about
what's gonna happen what's gonna happen
to the economy we'll talk about that
what's going on in Iran and and you know
a lot of times people are hearing
stories about how it really is in Iran
when you hear the stats of how things
are really in Iran you're going to sit
there and say there's no way in the
world that is true meaning if I just
gave you one stat right now before I
give you the rest of it what if I told
you in Iran they make nine-year-olds
turn into women to make them believe
they're ready to marry somebody if
somebody really wanted to marry them I
got some of these stats I give you about
a woman that you're gonna flip out on
what's going on in Iran and respect to a
lot of the uh you know people there that
are you know doing their part to create
their own Freedom we'll discuss that the
new the new Georgia Maloney who gave him
message in Italy and the amount of
criticism and love she's getting
simultaneously it's beautiful I'm sure
you sought a message what she gave a
powerful lot of enthusiasm people love
her it's weird how people around the
world are starting to vote for
conservative leaders Europe is supposed
to be left socialist but now they're
saying wait a minute we kind of need
some of the old school conservative um
beliefs which Adam's extremely excited
about we're going to talk about nuclear
war and what's going on a study from CBS
news that says a war between U.S and
Russia would kill fight a nuclear war
would kill 5 billion people that's the
only article that Adam didn't read cover
to cover thou hits bear markets mortgage
rates gone crazy luxury housing market
which the way to categorize luxury
housing market is the top five percent
of a market it's not saying it's a two
million dollar house three million
dollars top five percent of any City
luxury housing market dropped 28 in two
months it's the low it's the highest
we've had in 10 years that's a massive
drop-off that's saying a million dollar
house is 720. well yeah a 10 million
dollar house a 7.2 million dollars it's
a big number we're talking about and
it's not going to be slowing down and we
got a special message for Dave Ramsey
today because you know the Dave Ramsey
when he was watching a little too much
fear porn we're going to address the
fear porn concept he's obsessed with the
fear he maybe needs to watch a little
bit of fear porn because maybe he
doesn't watch report so Rasheed Rashida
Talib who gave a direct message to CEOs
and she tried to call out Jamie Diamond
and Jamie Diamond's response is
fantastic we'll go into the British
pound
plunged to an all-time low just in 2007
the pound was 211 it dropped to 103.
we'll cover that and then we got a
couple other stories Apple has decided
to make their phones in India record
number of New Yorkers are switching
their driver's license to Florida
billionaire bunkers around the world you
know Jeff Bezos is billionaire bunker
you should see this meaning if a war
nuclear war was to happen I think Bezos
is going to have a lot of fun in his
billionaire bunker
and then Bill Maher talks about the
prosthetic uh breast teacher massive
yeah which is you know which which
apparently it is a big story and we'll
cover that as well so having said that
having said that
um let's get right into it which story
do we want to talk about first real
quick can I just give all three of you
guys a warm welcome to Sunny South
Florida beautiful you guys have been
here man you guys the hurricane yeah
I've been here for three and a half
you've been here for I don't know three
months six months right six months year
and year and a half
year nine months January yeah whatever
it is you had you had an easy go your
first year here no hurricanes yeah yeah
you guys have never really experienced a
hurricane you've dealt with California
mudslides fires here I swam here but
welcome to Florida unless it's a four or
higher it's fine we don't lose no sleep
yeah Donnie yesterday says oh are you
concerned I said Donnie I've been bombed
on bro yeah
the difference between you see the
difference between earthquakes okay if
you've been through an earthquake yes if
you've been through a hurricane tornado
tornadoes are pretty Brutal by the way
when it hits you we went through that in
Kentucky in the Army and War you know
and then and then uh what's his name uh
uh Leo threw something else yesterday
when a blizzard not a blizzard when a uh
it's like a snowstorm when a snowstorm
hits in Minnesota he gave that have you
been through all of those take the war
thing out but have you been through an
earthquake every day I wake up no the
difference between an uh a hurricane is
you've got a week to it prepare
earthquake you don't know what's
happening tornado you don't know what's
happening yeah yeah we went through you
know I lived in Florida when I was a kid
I lived in Fort Myers so we my dad was a
part owner of a hotel the Best Western
out there and we had a hurricane that
was so bad that the first six floors the
hotel was maybe eight floors high if I'm
remembering correctly I was a baby I was
like four years old we had one that went
up to the fifth floor of the hotel just
wiped out everything so I was kid I was
like oh party time you know I heard this
I thought it was gonna be fun yeah kids
don't they don't really process anything
I had my family there I was like oh this
is great look at the window the trees oh
look that fell down so you know now I'm
like man but her kids don't scare me as
much for some reason I can't really
intellectualize why I think the
earthquake is the out of all those I
mean besides the war because we're from
the same place but the earthquake
there's no warning you'll just be a
mid-conversation and I don't care who
you are if you're not religious or
everybody's your first thing is it's
over we're done it's done you've been
through earthquakes since earthquakes
that woke me up from asleep yeah yeah
because stuff's falling off the yeah but
Tampa Bay is gonna get hit pretty bad so
hopefully Tom Brady can do something
about that they're all moving Tampa
Bay's gonna get it but here's my
question with all our technology mind
you I know you guys saw NASA just had a
dart mission that they sent seven
Million Miles Away uh asteroid and they
hit it with the with an object to make
it just in case the asteroid comes to
his successful Mission they can't with
our technology do something for the
tornado or hurricane and make it just
call it racism
in a very very good question and there
are people that are working on that yeah
that you know because what they have
created now is how to create a storm
they know how to create a storm they
know how to create rain they know how to
create that if you can create it you got
to figure out a way to try to undo it
yeah what do you mean they can create a
storm
clouds precipitation Middle East all the
time do they really happen in Dubai
they're like it's gonna rain on Thursday
and it happens wow look at that
technology they can create we don't need
to deal with that in Florida it rains a
lot of time so we're not looking for
less rain here yeah we're good so that's
in the Middle East they need that so do
we want to start with like a business
story to get Vince's uh feedback on
these business stores I say we start off
with a business wait let's go right into
a business story Wall Street Tycoon you
know with everything that's going on
just go straight to Dave Ramsey okay go
to Dave Ramsey I want to start off with
them so Dave Ramsey a few months ago I
need the exact date on this post by the
way that's what June 29th that's June
29th fantastic so go to June 29th let's
see what the Market was at on June 29th
go to Dow Jones June 29th yeah June 29th
okay
all right so let's look at it that was
what
pull it up June 29th uh okay you're
gonna look at it that way uh uh maybe
let's look at it in a basic way
if you take Dow Jones and you go six
months and you go straight to the date
uh I'll find it right now I'm on June
29th June 29th that was at 31 000 and
change okay fine June 29th uh you know
the Dave Ramsey says the following let
me read it to the audience so they can
see it
if you can go to the Post writer okay
the housing market is not crashing it's
by Dave Ramsey inflation recession High
interest rates High fuel costs labor
market disruption including the great
resignation supply chain shortages bear
Market
and the hits just keep coming are we
heading for the end of American economy
is the housing market going to crash is
this generation going to be priced out
of the housing market and never be
homeowners no no no three no's so that's
three notes so that means he's saying no
two are we headed to the end of American
economy of course not is the housing
market going to crash that's the
question that we want to address the
second one says is this generation going
to be priced out of the housing market
and never be homeowners that's also no I
agree with that one the main one I want
to Target is the middle one is the
housing market going to crash he said no
sorry to end your fear porn party but
the sky is really not falling it's
definitely scary and some of the things
going on truly do suck but the sky's not
falling when you're operating on fear
fight or flight chemicals flood your
brain and your critical thinking skills
shut down higher thought patterns and
Analysis are only possible when a
perceived threat is uh lowered you don't
ever make good decisions based on
thinking you do when you're afraid or
angry and the new cycle right now will
make you both angry and Afraid several
times a day if you let the drama in so
the porn party is still going so
basically yeah so no what he's saying is
don't worry about it it's all going to
be all right so I just finished a book
it's called how to my default it's by
Jim Collins okay Jim Collins wrote a
book years ago called good to great so
in this book uh how to Mighty Fall he
makes a he asks a very very good
question okay which is a rebuttal to
this here because it is a battle he make
he's he's he's giving the motivational
positive thinking everything's gonna be
all right mindset which is something I
subscribe to my entire life however
there's a caveat to it in the book Jim
Collins says you have two options here
okay say you're somebody who is always
optimistic and you say things like I'm
the best I'm great we're gonna do
fantastic we know what we're doing we're
the best in the marketplace no one's
better than us we're gonna go do this
okay and then the other mindset is what
the mindset of person says I don't know
if I'm good enough to compete man I
don't know if I have what it takes to
compete in the podcast I don't know if I
don't know if what if the rates drop in
real estate and what if that happens and
what if I'm not good enough to be a
father what if I'm not good enough to be
a husband or a mother or a wife or what
if I'm what if I don't have the goodies
here but man I if I don't call that
person what if that client changes their
mind so you're always in that I'm not
good enough to get to the next level
right he says two companies have two
different types of leaders say one is
thinking like everything's gonna be
great and the other one is dude we got a
lot of we got some improving to do right
he says let's look at the first option
if the first option if you're right
guess what everything's great
if you're wrong
you're problematic you're going to go
out of business
but in the second situation if you're
wrong who cares but if you're right good
for you you're going to keep improving
meaning if you look at this and you say
oh is the market going to crash nah it's
not going to Mark and the Market's not
going to crash
yeah it's gonna be all right don't even
sweat it all this stuff okay then rates
come up okay
to 6.29 percent I don't know if you saw
the Yahoo finance thing I'm gonna send
this to you so you can show it because I
think it's very important for us to see
this
luxury home pricing I'll text this to
you we have it in the article as well
but Tyler if you want to look at your
phone I'm sending it to you uh receive
that one and I'll send you the other one
as well you guys have to see this here
on what the numbers of luxury as well as
uh I'll send you this other one as well
pull these two up if you can pull both
of them up if you can okay so that's one
of them take a look at this this is from
Yahoo finance
this is luxury home sales sink most on
record
that's from 2013. okay look at the
luxury Market it goes down a little bit
in 2014 then in 2020 it drops during
covet dramatically but as bad as it
dropped during covid look how bad it's
dropped after Colvin so meaning covet
was fake it's all fear that six-month
period right there in 2020 2020 that was
not a real crash the market still went
up but look at the drop from the top to
the bottom that is a 28 drop from June
to August highest in 10 years we're
talking about okay so then outside of
that inventory is officially up okay
inventory is going up mortgage rates if
you got the mortgage rates I sent you I
don't know if you got that one as well
if you want to go to the next one I just
sent you take a look at this one here
it's not slowing down go to the next one
ask you a really quick question why is
it because I think you're going there
right now luxury dropped that much what
about just regular regular homes luxury
luxury went up too much and it was
overpriced and now how people are not
willing to pay as many different reasons
they can look at but look at this one
right here rates from 2021 till today
2.85 to 6.29 and it's constantly gone up
the 30 year is 6.29 15 year is 5.44 and
the five-year arm is 4.97 so the concept
of fear Point here's a part then then
people say well does this mean the the
bear Market is here is this the end of
it is this like Pat what's going to
happen next let me show you this other
one here and then we'll do some
commentary
I'm going to read the Dao hits bear
Market as stocks sell off okay if you
want to go to page five uh Tyler if you
have that article if not I'll just read
it to the audience this is very
important to pay attention to okay so
down here it's bear Market as stock
sell-off goes from bad to worse the Dow
average on Friday briefly hit a bear
Market before bouncing back from
slightly a 700 point to drop the average
is now sitting at the lowest since
November 2020 which is covet this is the
S P 500 NASDAQ Composite Raptor second
High straight week of losses retreating
to June lows the payment pain may
continue following the Federal Reserve
75 basis point rate hike and new
projected 4.4 percent Federal fund rate
a percentage Point higher than initial
forecast the team at Goldman Sachs led
by David costen cut their cut their
Outlook of the S P 500 this year by 16
to 3600 versus a prior of 4300 as the
economy faces the likelihood of sharp
downturn or hard Landing
when you see numbers like this atom what
do you think about what do you think
about what Dave Ramsey talking about the
you know real estate's not going to
crash and then you see the market
dipping 28 specifically on real estate
how do you process that I mean I'm
looking from a macro perspective I think
I mean the world has changed so much in
the last two years right I mean I think
everything we've gone through with covid
and the markets and real estate and
masks and lockdowns and and recessions
and this that I think everyone
is looking for stability at this point
so there's so many people saying I know
that the Market's going to go up
Market's not going to go down this is
what happened with Kobe this is what's
going on in the world economic Forum
like there's so many different things
going on and I think it's incumbent on
you as an individual to seek stability
in your life there's going to be experts
telling you XYZ up down left right yeah
I think it's very important for you as
an individual to take ownership in your
life and say how the can I make my life
better and tune out the noise we're
literally going through a hurricane
right now like in Florida and I feel
like the entire world from a to use a
metaphor is going through a financial uh
social socioeconomic hurricane and in
the middle of this crazy storm that's
going on you you know the calm and the
eye of the storm is the is the only
place in the middle of a hurricane where
there's actually not craziness going on
so in all the craziness of the world you
need to figure out where that stability
can come from in your life whether
that's God whether that's family whether
that's politics whether that's just you
know your own individual freedoms
whatever it is you need to find that
certain to your life I don't know if
Ramsay's right I don't know if he's
wrong I don't know if Jamie diamonds
right I don't know if he's wrong but you
need to kind of find the voice of reason
in your life and find your center of
gravity and figure it out for yourself
because nobody's coming to save you you
got to save yourself great great enough
I love the the fear pouring conversation
though um just because I feel like we've
seen that explode so much in society
over the last two years and fear has
played a role in people's Health
decisions where people live how they
live it's had a huge impact on the way
parents raise children now you have a
lot of kids that are growing up afraid
of literally everything because their
parents are now afraid of everything
because they've been through coven and
it's affecting Society at large in so
many ways it affected the way the school
system runs so people are in a very
different head right now and I'm
wondering if there's just going to be a
pretty enormous backlash to this which
means that a lot of people were making
decisions based on fear and now are
looking back and seeing the negative
ramifications of that on them themselves
and their families and I'm wondering if
now there's going to be people rising up
refusing to do that again with the
complete opposite uh mindset of I'm not
going to live in fear I'm not going to
let these things you know prevent me
from excelling I'm not going to be you
know stymied by what a political
bureaucrat or what Society tells me I
should be afraid of because what I'm
seeing now is kind of like a a lion kind
of like Roar from a lot of people who
bought into the fear and now just refuse
to live that way just seeing how
negatively it affected their families
over the course the last two years but
but also it kind of depends where you're
at in life and this is why I love a
freaking America so much because you
could say well you know recession in
America and the markets and all that
it's like pump the brakes a little bit
everybody we're still in America we're
still in the greatest country on Earth
if you're in the middle of Ukraine or if
you're in you know the Philippines or
you know certain countries out there
they're not exactly stable you're living
in a constant state of here I mean if
you're in a round right now if you're in
Russia right now if you just called up
into the militia or if you're one of
these young women who's basically
protesting for their lives you know
you're in a constant state of fear so
um you know from a macro perspective
just appreciate what we got here in
America I was I was dude trust me I was
scared as hell and up like I said
earlier I don't know nothing about
business I went to Adam we had that talk
we sat down Adam hooked me up with you
know Vinnie and does do this he goes
invest in the S P 500 I'm so stupid I
thought it was a NASCAR race are they
racing on Sunday he goes no not now he
goes NASDAQ not NASCAR I go oh okay like
an idiot but hey scared the hell out of
me so and that's why we're the number
one biggest in the world thank you by
the way so here's here's how I process
this here's how I process this okay I I
grew up in business the first five ten
years all I subscribed to was Power of
Positive Thinking by Norman Vincent peel
and that's all it was okay
and then you realize there's levels to
to life so for example the most basic
thing you can do is buy term investing
not by term investor difference dollar
cost averaging right or by term investor
difference is one of the ones that they
will talk about but you know dollar cost
averaging you know put your money every
single month by 200 of a mutual fund 500
of mutual fund thousand dollars a mutual
fund on ETF and leave it there 30 years
you know you're going to get a certain
set of return the Market's gonna crash
you know and by the way I have a mutual
fund today that I've been putting money
into for nearly 20 years and I started
20 years ago and I started with 100
bucks a month okay and it's grown into a
very nice account I don't even look at
it but it's grown into
a nice little Hefty account that I
started with 100 bucks a month okay that
philosophy works but many times when a
message like this is given a baby boomer
who's sitting there thinking the
Market's gonna be okay the Market's not
going to be okay for the baby boomer
baby boomer was expecting to retire at
64 years old who's 63 today has to now
work to 70 years old because somebody
didn't give him the right counsel the
part with giving counsel is your counsel
has to be given to whatever situation
you're currently in okay that's the part
about giving counsel specifically when
it comes down to finances a a council
like this that you give to say that the
housing market is not going to crash
it's not going to be this it's not going
to be that and then the market does
crash the real estate does crash and you
say rather than saying this you say just
in case this happens be prepared in the
following way by the way Tyler do you
have that clip from the guy that says
the government doesn't if he can pull up
this one clip just play this clip and go
to I don't know play uh go to 45 seconds
yeah about a minute or so go to a minute
and press play I see an opportunity to
make money I go with a happy make them
feel more confident
listen to what this guy says 12 years
ago
personally it doesn't matter that that's
it see I'm a Trader I don't really care
about that kind of stuff I go with what
the I if I see an opportunity to make
money I go with that um so for most
Traders it's not about it's that we
don't really care that much how they're
going to fix the how they're going to
fix the economy how they're going to fix
the uh the whole situation our job is to
make money from it and personally I've
been dreaming of this one for three
years I I had a confession which is I go
to bed every night I dream of another
recession I dream of another Moment Like
This why because uh people don't seem to
maybe remember but the 30s depression
the depression 1930s wasn't just about a
market crash there were some people who
were prepared to make money from that
that's the part and that's what anybody
can talk about it isn't just for some
people in the elite listen to the ladies
anybody can actually make money it's an
opportunity uh when the market crashes
uh when the Euro and the big stock
markets crash if you know what to do
um
if you have the right plan to set up uh
you can you can make a lot of money from
this uh for example
hedging strategies is one uh
um
investing in bonds treasury bonds that
sort of stuff see the people around me
jaws have collectively dropped at what
you've just said I mean we appreciate
your candor however it doesn't help the
rest of us does it all the rest of the
Euro Zone listen I would say this to
everybody who's watching this
this economic crisis is like a cancer if
you just wait and wait thinking this is
going to go away just like a cancer is
going to grow and it's going to be too
late what I would say to everybody is
get prepared
there's another time right now to
um which we'll think in the government
is going to sort things out the
governments don't rule the world Goldman
Sachs rules the world
right so so what do you take from that
message just as as a person maybe you're
not in finance when you hear that how do
you process what he just said since I
dream about a recession happens every 10
years in the 30s a lot of wealth was
created government doesn't run
everything Goldman how do you process it
it's up to you when [ __ ] it's a fan it's
up to you to to take advantage has been
saying this forever it's an opportunity
it's I mean it's not a really good
looking opportunity but you have to jump
on and be ready like right now just just
from hearing that in my head I'm like I
have to ask both of you after this What
bond should I be looking at and what you
know Goldman Sachs what the hell are
they up to because just be ready just be
prepared because like right now I mean
Pat do you guys think it's going to be I
mean it's the White House is you know
they beat us every single day
everything's fine borders fine economy
is great everything's fine when I'm I
know we talked about it 13 months you
said so now we're getting to like the
six or seven more months so everything
goes kaputs you think we're still going
towards that so just look at it this way
this is this is what I said the other
day okay
and if you go to Dow Jones history of
Dow Jones just go to history Dow Jones
this is all you need to know okay just
type in doubt yeah history of Dow Jones
High you know uh oh let me see if you
can pull this up or not if you can go
Max how many years back does it go to uh
82. okay what was it at 82 907. okay
what is it in 1990
go to 1990. it's 2600. okay what's that
two thousand
uh Ten rounds okay what's that 2010.
um 10 grand okay what's that 2020.
so here's the point guy and what was it
a 1980 go all the way back to what it
was 27 I think 907 907 guys so meaning
it went from 907 to 10 grand to 20 grand
to 30 grand
the Dow in the next 40 years so if it
was at 40 so if we take 907 into 30
what's 907 into 30. roughly 35 times
okay 33 times right 35 times
so that means if we take 30 000 today
okay thirty thousand thirty thousand
down today and we do times 35 is what
that means that will be at a million in
42 years
so meaning long term you're gonna be
fine long term Innovation is going to be
fine but for people that are sitting
there saying I truly want to create
wealth you have to if you have some
savings right now you did it right
you're going to be able to capitalize
because a lot of things are going to be
on sale you're going to buy a condo a
house on nothing in my opinion in the
next 12 months the level of discounted
properties is going to be insane in 12
months like discount in a way that you
never thought you'd be paying that kind
of a discount on 12 months but you have
to also be thinking about this is if
you're if you're 30 years old this is
probably going to happen only five times
in your lifetime wow if you're 40 years
old it's probably only going to happen
four times in your lifetime if you're 20
years old six times wow you have to be
ready for your the next one that's going
to happen in 10 years and the way you do
that is by piling up a bunch of cash and
you make some good Investments and 10
years from now you're ready when it
happens again because we're gonna go
through the cyclical cycle so my my uh
uh my uh prediction is the following who
gave birth to Ronald Reagan
Jimmy Carter okay who's the closest
president to Jimmy Carter Joseph Biden
Joseph Biden and how long was Jimmy how
long was Ronald Reagan president eight
years who became the next president his
VP senior so Republicans stayed for 12
years then what happened after 12 years
Clinton showed up that's eight years
what happened after Clinton GW what
happened after him Obama what happened
you don't have terms going to be one one
term there's going to be 2-1 tournaments
so we haven't had a 1-1 tournament in a
long time wow you get what I'm saying
it's going to be a one-one terming Biden
is not the best
well you'll see the numbers that we're
looking at so the point is this this
economy the way it's going this is going
to give birth to a conservative
president for the next eight years
whether it's going to be a DeSantis
whether it's going to be a trump if it's
a DeSantis and it follows Carter's
Playbook whoever DeSantis chooses as VP
could most likely end up being the next
president as well so if the census picks
pick a name I don't know just give me
any name Nikki Haley yeah okay give me
any name it's not going to be Nikita but
let's just say it's going to be Nikki
Haley sorry 12 years now so that's 12
years okay then the Market's gonna sit
there and say whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa a
little too much yeah Richard getting too
rich this is not fair you have too many
trillionaires why should Elon Musk be a
trillionaire then it's gonna flip but
all I'm saying is during this time folks
here's all I'm saying Andy Grove I'm
gonna keep saying this as many times as
possible who ran a company called Intel
that grew a hundred percent rate that
everybody in Silicon Valley swore by
this Hungarian guy that built one of the
best stories in Silicon Valley he wrote
a book and the book was called only the
paranoid survive simple as that and too
many people are not paranoid today I'm
gonna do great people are good only the
paranoid survive so you need a little
bit of that mindset of only the
paranoids survive today because if you
don't in a market tanks because here's
what happens if Dave Ramsey is right
guess what nothing changes great he's
right but if Dave Ramsey is wrong a lot
of people who listen to him are screwed
because they sat there saying the
Market's not going to crash he didn't
prepare them to say it could potentially
happen anyways we're going to see what's
going to happen here with the store can
I add something to that I also think
it's where you're at in life like every
single one of us anything with everyone
listening right now
you could look in the mirror and say how
far can I think out how far can I think
outward you know two-thirds of Americans
are living paycheck to paycheck I don't
care how positive or optimistic you're
what kind of plan they have in place if
you're struggling to figure out how
you're going to pay your next bill next
week next month the next quarter it's
hard for you to have a plan for what's
going to happen you know 12 24 months
from now but the the goal is to get to
the point where you can think that way
right so I'm at a point where I'm not
worried about week to week day to day
month to month even year to year at this
point because I set the wheels in motion
15 years ago 12 years ago okay how can I
get from week to week to month to month
boom all right got it I'm no longer
month to month all right how can I get
from month to month to year to year boom
I'm no longer figuring out year to year
and now I'm in a perspective where I'm
thinking five years from now where do I
want to be in life and that's what I'm
planning for right now but if you're
like how the hell am I going to get to
think long term it's like well just
you know you know crawl before you walk
walk before you run run before you walk
a marathon so wherever you're at in life
just think about what's the next step so
if I'm Vinnie I'm thinking all right
cool I'm no longer month to month how
can I get that I'm no longer thinking
year to year at this point and that's
just the next evolution of your step of
your life so that's where you got to
kind of look in the mirror where are you
at in life right now what's the next
step the next goal that I should be
reaching towards because whether it's
the stock market whether that's
relationships whether that's real estate
whether that's your even your health if
you're focused on day to day you're
never going to be able to win meaning
I'm going to fight with my girl stock
market's up right I'm not feeling well
covered whatever it's like but if you
can extrapolate over time it's kind of
exactly what you're saying about the Dow
and 40 years from now it's going to hit
a million but if you can kind of have
that long-term perspective rather than
being myopic day to day week to week
you'll win in the end it's just hard to
get to that long-term perspective yeah
okay but here's my question Pat I hope
you can expand on this do we make it 40
years so we're at 31 trillion dollars in
debt right yeah I'm looking at numbers
I'm seeing a few oh my God 2022 fiscal
year the government spent seven trillion
5 trillion 9 trillion whatever you know
it was 740 billion dollars in the
inflation reduction act like when you
factor in unfunded liabilities worth 300
trillion dollars in debt this is
unsustainable yeah Adam's talking about
thinking about year to year to year
we're not doing that we're thinking day
to day today and we're spending much
money as humanly possible we are
printing money
I don't I don't know how this is
sustainable I don't know how we make it
40. that looks like a casino I thought
that was like a game on a casino floor
like what is that real it's the deck
this is the day and this doesn't work
go to domestic GDP I thought we were
like about the bet on something go to
domestic GDP all right well God so I'm
just gonna boil this down to obviously
this is disgusting you see all the red
no doubt but if you're Tyler makes a
point though I'm curious total jet just
said GDP is 100 we need to figure out
the debt situation but whether it's the
U.S economy or you're even your own
individual household economy yeah
there's two sides to every financial
plan there's offense and defense thank
God we still have the number one offense
in the freaking world the United States
of America GDP is what 25 trillion right
where are we at GDP wise okay 25
trillion so it's not like we're some
crumbling economy that can't sustain
paying our bills we just got to figure
out how to stop running up the credit
card oh I don't know about that let's so
so look here's
uh so you know when when we when we
first started the insurance company
I I recruited a a husband and wife
wife's name was Diana and she sat me
down it's December 31st of 2010. it's 4
50. a guy's coming to do for me to sign
a contract to take over a lease in
Woodland Hills at the Warner Center
Marriott and she says I I want to come
work with you but you seem like you're a
little bit too aggressive and I'm
worried that you know the insurance
company is going to have challenges
because of the finances that you're
going to have some reckless spending
that's going to cost the company to go
out of business
and I look at it I'm like that's a fair
concern I said but the part that you
don't know and the only way I can tell
you is that there's a lot of things I'm
very frugal with which allows me to make
the tougher decisions when we need money
right company starts
do you know in the history of the
insurance company I was never the
highest paid guy in the company I've
never been the highest paid guy in the
company okay never I've been including
value payment I'm not the highest paid
guy in the company highest paid salary
I'm not in the company right
but what we did is we took the money and
we stayed very paranoid for example till
today
if I have to pay AV comes and says to us
80 000 is the bid and you know typically
people who are taking the bid aquapets
eighty thousand dollars I'm like I'm not
paying eighty thousand dollars let me
see the bid no go back to them for sixty
two thousand dollars we settle that
sixty five thousand dollars we just say
fifteen thousand dollars now somebody
may say who cares about that fifteen
thousand dollars it's fifteen thousand
dollars right yeah well you know here's
how we have to go this is all it is I
said you sure this is how much the
camera is yes and I'll go online so the
other day guys coming to set up the
internet system at our house because we
want to watch the fights in the Cabana
in the back instead of so we can smoke
the cigars and I'm setting it up so it's
gonna cost you 130 000 oh really yeah
what's your coupon you got I'm on the
zoom with them and I'm going pricing at
all the equipment myself and I'm looking
I said why are you charging me this much
and why are you charging me this much
three of the things I was able to save
four or five thousand dollars but one of
the things I I uh he gets it cheaper
than I do for wholesale well I looked at
wholesalers like you notice I can get a
cheaper than you I said Fair that's fine
but I need you to lower these to this
anyways the whole thing ended up being
fifty nine thousand dollars wow to get
internet set up in the background what
was the initial quote 100 something or
some thousand but we have the structure
where we look at three different offers
on anything we buy no matter what we do
I don't think our government is paranoid
enough with this debt I don't think the
American people are paranoid I don't
think a lot of CEOs today unfortunately
500 are paranoid I don't think a lot of
people who are saying just take the
vaccine or just take this I don't think
enough people are praying how much
research do we have on the I think too
many people have become like ah it's
okay no man no you got a wife you got a
husband you got kids you need you're the
leader of the pack you need to be a
little bit hesitant about what's going
on do your own research before you
jumped in conclusion with everything
we've become a little bit too look yeah
okay uh-huh yeah yeah no no I don't know
I don't know what's going on with this I
don't know what's going on with the
mortgage side so we need to be a little
bit more from that perspective unless if
you're the type of a person my dad told
me something we had a a uncle named
Albert favorite uncle we had
he would come Sundays and he only wanted
to watch one show on Sundays do you know
the story or no he would come to my
house doesn't speak any English Okay a
Syrian guy okay Albert okay the only guy
that would give me a hundred dollars for
my birthday really every birthday and I
love him for it I eventually I took him
to a cruise in uh Caribbean with my dad
I said listen for every hundred dollars
you just want to meet I'm flying you out
we're gonna have a blast you have done
so much for me I love you he's in uh
he's in the hospital you just gotta you
know I love Albert family's special
family they changed my life but uh one
day my he comes and Albert comes in on
Sundays he says I said Albert the usual
yeah put it I want to watch it in
Assyrian
he wanted to watch Kings of Comedy
because he wanted to watch Bernie Mac
wow he's watched a Bernie Mac from Kings
of Comedy if I tell you 100 times that's
a small number I said do you know what
he just said he says no two four of a
six-year-old God help me baby cities so
you we would watch this not a bad
burning so then he says to me he says
the two-year-old Shepherd for the devil
whatever the two-year-old said I know
the whole thing because of Albert
because I've watched this party maxing
so many times here's the point I'm
scared of you [ __ ]
so my dad sits me down and we're in the
kitchen it says look at Albert
and he says what about it he says just
look at him look how happy he is
he says he says that's the happiest
person I know in my life so look at him
he says be very careful reading these
books I said why he says because the
moment you have too much knowledge
you're gonna lose the innocence of being
happy because you know nothing yeah
exactly so you that was Albert that was
Albert so the point you have to choose
in life unless if you just want to live
a innocent happy life that you're just
chilling kicking and not giving a [ __ ]
about he couldn't even know you asking
what the Dow Jones is he's gonna think
it's a lady next story hell down I said
hello you know but the but the point is
if you choose to really pick up a book
and read you can enter a world us right
damn I better kind of learn to make some
adjustments but if you just want to live
a life like Albert dude more power to
you every family needs an Albert
this is ignorant
I'm not going to touch a goddamn well
this is the the difference between
ignorance is bliss and as what we talk
about red pill or blue pill oh my god do
you wanna I think the problem is two
things right you showed the debt clock
and your reaction is amazing because I
think a lot of people just first of all
it's too big these numbers are too big
you can't even contextualize what this
means it's like it's too much worse and
what people do is they look at that and
they say oh 30 trillion dollars and you
know what we're fine we're okay we're
not like nothing's blowing up nothing's
happening right in their immediate
backyard where they can say that's why
so they say this is just too much I
can't even wrap my head around it
whatever it'll fix itself there's that
type of attitude it's not relatable to
people people need to say this 30
trillion dollars how does that affect
you how is that if it if you don't tell
people how it's going to affect them
personally their family their paycheck
they're not interested I agree that's
number one and I think secondly I think
this attitude of what Pat brought up of
not asking questions it's almost like
we're being trained now to just accept
things as they are like oh debt this is
the new Norm this is the new Norm you
have to accept it it's just the way
things go if you don't have debt you're
not going to have nice things if you
don't have debt we're not going to be
able to invest in education if you don't
have debt we're not going to get this so
people like well we have to have debt
because if we don't have debt we're not
going to have all this stuff so and
people don't want to really look at the
root cause of the issues which is that
we spend a ton of money on things that
do absolutely nothing it's a complete
waste there's a ton of bureaucracy
that's not necessary waste fraud abuse
nobody wants to do the hard work
including by the way Democrats and
Republicans in Congress who don't give
two shits about these numbers they don't
care they'll pile them on until Kingdom
Come doesn't affect them they're going
to be fine they're not worried about you
so this is not a red versus blue problem
this is a government problem and people
need to start the thing is you can be
you can have that state of bliss that's
great and I used to be be a person let
me tell you I went through college I
studied literature I didn't read the
newspaper I was dating a guy who was
into economics he was an economics
professor actually he was always like
hey did you read the New York Times
today and I was like no I didn't because
I want to have a nice day so you're out
you know you're out I was she was and
the problem I love it I love it I was a
happy son of a [ __ ] in college I smiled
ear to ear I didn't need any of that
[ __ ] but here's the problem you grow up
that's great in college you then become
an adult and this [ __ ] hits your
backyard you then have a child and this
[ __ ] hits your child you then try to
save money and this [ __ ] hits you so
that state of bliss if you really want
to start saving if you really want to
build a business you can't live in that
Bliss because that Bliss is not real so
you know I get it I get the head believe
me there's days I'm like man do I just
go open a spa somewhere and just I don't
know what to do with myself just not to
worry about all this but you have to
figure out a way here's the thing people
figure out a way to look at it be
realistic about it figure out how it
affects your family don't get scared of
it strategize around it strategize
around it and you have to understand you
can't control all this but you can
control some of it you can control what
happens at The Ballot Box I'm not saying
that that person that gets elected is
going to care deeply about debt but you
know what you make certain decisions
someone might care a little bit more
than someone else you can make decisions
about where you put your kids in school
you can make decisions about where you
live you can make decisions about what
job you get don't allow these big
numbers to make you feel powerless and
also don't pretend they don't exist it's
real this is reality you don't have to
be buried by it but you do have to be
cognizant of it yeah that's right I
agree I am I'm a hundred percent with
her on what she said powerful way to
transition into the next topic quick
shout out to some of the super chats
guys if you got questions put a Super
Chat we may go through some of yours uh
thoughts on mortgage-backed Securities
crashing Miguel uh gave 20 bucks thank
you for that you think we're surprised I
don't know why anybody's surprised it's
going to continue going that direction
next SN networks are nice to see
Avengers assembly again with love from
Sweden uh you are more than welcome
Scott Rodriguez 50 bucks attitude is a
little thing that makes a big difference
friends you're right Scotty Success is
Not final failure is not fatal it is the
courage to continue that count If You're
Going Through Hell keep going everyone
has his day and some days last longer
than others we have a fatimura huge fan
of the show love what you guys are doing
path you always invite guests with
opposing views to your own which really
brings value to the audience have you
found anyone with a real argument
supporting the economy Fadi I will tell
you this though right this seat right
here is available for Dave Ramsey to
come and sit down and talk all day long
I think the audience would win I'd be
more than happy to sit down and have a
conversation with them or anybody else
you want to recommend put a
recommendation down or tell us on
Twitter and tag them and then we'll
retweet it and go from there uh Captain
Ahmed gave 20 bucks from Australia best
podcast love from Australia love you
Scott Rodriguez I want a cookie
all right next next topic do we want to
talk about Iran or do you want to go
into a lighter subject we want to talk
about Iran our families are from there
we might as well so Iran uh obviously
it's been a mess uh if you've seen some
of the the videos we talked about it I
think on the last podcast on what is
taking place is there place there at a
reaction video I did to it but a few
things that people need to know what he
run you know everybody lives their lives
and does their own thing but sometimes
when you actually see what is really
going on and what the climate in Iran is
you know a lot of people left right
center it doesn't matter what it is
there are certain things that we all
agree on when it comes down to men and
women okay the basic basic things that
we all agree on where everybody should
be treated equally when it comes down to
voting marriage divorce you know all
that stuff but let me just give you some
stats folks this is Iran and you tell me
how you feel about this would you be
okay living in a country that accepted
this at age seven girls in Iran are
forced to wear headscarves to attend
elementary school they can't go to
school if they don't comply according to
the Islamic law if you kill someone you
have to pay some sort of atonement blood
money to the family of the victim you
ready for this one the money you have
have to pay for killing a woman is half
the money you have to pay for a man okay
that is in Iran women don't have the
right to divorce their husbands they're
basically stuck in their marriages as
long as possible their husbands want
them to be men have the rights to
divorce their wives whenever they want
being gay queer is illegal the
punishment for death for being gay in
Iran is death penalty having a dog is
illegal you can't take your dog out for
a walk the police will can literally
take away your dog and kill it if they
want to that's true I wonder what they
do too I think if they have a cat they
kill the dog and the cat and the owner
is what they do everybody goes down the
cat is like you gotta be careful with
that one they throw a stupid puberty
ceremony for us when they turn nine they
brainwash girls with this is a day you
turn into a woman at nine years old they
make us wear chador similar to Abaya on
that day and force us to say Islamic
prayers and Iranian man is allowed to
have four wives at the same time Iranian
women should be stoned thrown Stones
until death if they are proven to have
committed infidelity partying is illegal
dancing is illegal singing is in go for
women women are not allowed to play
musical instruments in public satellite
TV is illegal you can't go to the beach
and sunbathe and swim with your entire
family because it's illegal young girls
are forced into marriages with men they
barely know girls as young as nine years
old are forced into these marriages does
this sound like a place you want to live
in does it sound like a place now here's
the thing though this is the part
yesterday I was doing a podcast with
this guy David a Jewish guy very
interesting podcast he didn't like what
Tate stood for so he's got a big
following on Twitter we did a podcast
together it was very entertaining and
you know I said to him I said here's the
part on why I love everything being
public because ideas good or bad social
media makes people listen to what I just
read right now and some of you may have
chills all over your body and you're
saying that's unfreaking believable that
is horrible and then the world gets to
say these are horrible ideas and Common
Sense eventually wins a conservative
women
prime minister of Italy who's one of the
top socialist countries in the world do
you remember the covet breakout in Italy
just two and a half years ago what they
did with the shutdown the country said
we don't want this yeah you're seen in
Iran women are out there marching
protesting I got calls yesterday I'm
talking trying to do an interview with
the shot sound Reza palavi we're talking
to Darius we're talking to all these
guys to see if we can put on a concert
to support what Iran I'm talking to all
these different musicians these people
that are calling me big name celebrities
in the Iranian community
people are saying we're sick of it
because bad ideas get exposed and that's
exactly what's happened in Iran today
which is a great thing by the way Elon
Musk did activate starlink for Iran
which I think if you ask me all these
you know the other day uh Joe Biden gave
a human humanitarian I think uh award to
uh Elton John yeah
and I'm sitting there saying when are
you guys going to give a Nobel Prize to
Elon Musk I'm going to keep saying that
until these guys realize you're
activating starting to give free
internet access to places like Iran
where we can see exactly what's going on
and people can make a decision because
the government it's a sad situation what
are your thoughts being from there as
well the first thing just on the Elon
Musk because the government shut down
the internet right on the internet yes
and you guys will film it the first
thing when I saw this past especially
because my mom and dad are from Iran the
first thing I don't know why it jumped
to it is is the the people here
especially some of these hardcore
feminist women I go they don't they
don't know nothing about this right they
complain about how horrible this place
is but think about it as a woman in the
United States you can go to college you
could have 90 cats nobody's gonna say
[ __ ] you could sleep with everybody on
the team you can get out become a CEO
you could do whatever you could go on
the streets March make up with the girl
take your clothes off burn the flag say
hashtag kill all men nothing happens
this poor girl her hat was crooked and
the morality police they have [ __ ]
morality police sorry for my language
beat her to death okay so anytime I hear
anybody complain especially those
feminists about this place because Pat
you nailed it they don't know those they
don't they don't know those stats and to
be honest you they don't give a [ __ ]
they don't care so some from now on I'm
not saying this to those people that are
just so anti-america take a time out
take a step back look what's going on
nobody knows bro you can't have a dog
that's like the least one at all you
can't have it's illegal to have a dog
you're you're forcing people to wear
kids on their heads you know I mean like
it's a perspective nobody knows nobody
cares great uh great perspective by
Vinnie and I appreciate that I remember
when remember when Pharrell uh song came
out so I'm happy yeah and then there's a
group of people in Iran that just wanted
to be happy and sing the song
we never heard from them again ever
again they just wanted to be happy I
think to to your point about
um Elon Musk and starlink in the Nobel
Peace Prize
look for Millennia what were the three
basic necessities that everyone needed
to survive Food Water Shelter okay and
then over the last couple hundred years
that TR that that went to Food Water
Shelter money and resources right so it
went from three to four now today Food
Water Shelter money internet access how
many people are going to survive around
the world without internet access
internet access I mean the one thing
people in Iran will need the one thing
Elon Musk is bringing to the table was
starlink is freaking internet so they
can shine a light on what's happening
there without it being basically in the
dark because like you said nobody knows
this kind of stuff no nine-year-old
stuff this seven-year-old stuff no
dancing no being happy [ __ ] can't
even have a dog no this is what the
moolahs are doing in Iran yeah you know
there's an interesting parallel to him
here though you know listening to this
because there is a thirst for Freedom
around the world you know you're talking
about Iran we can talk about Italy
there's a thirst for Freedom popping up
except here except the land of the free
what is happening here where is the
thirst for freedom here what I see in
the United States is the opposite what I
see is a spoiled privileged complacent
population and you know it's interesting
you talk about women's rights over there
what Vinnie was saying is true you're
talking about re this is what real
discrimination looks like thank you this
is active discrimination when you talk
about women's rights in the United
States right now you know what you talk
about allowing women to do late term
abortions on babies so we who's lost
here we are we are lost we are a society
that we are supposed to be the land of
the free we are supposed to be what
other places look to and say we want to
do that what are we doing we have a
bunch of people in this country and it's
a large segment of the population that
is very comfortable with being
subservient to Authority at all costs
Authority tells you to lock down your
business and you're like okay Authority
tells you to put a mask on your kid and
send them to school even though there's
no data to support it okay Authority
tells you to get a mandatory injection
that your doctor told you is not good
for you okay we just watched that unfold
for two years so there is something
wrong here and and we have to we have to
really address that because you can talk
about what's going on around the world
and everyone says oh America is a beacon
of Liberty you can't even point to the
military anymore you used to be able to
point to the U.S military and say the
U.S military has one Mission they have
one Mission they have one passion no
it's a bunch of people watching woke
videos that look like they were built
for small children it looks like Blue's
Clues you've got the military sitting
and watching Blue's Clues for the woke
yep so this is a huge problem and until
we face it within ourselves you know
what's going to happen you're going to
wind up seeing Freedom fights in other
countries that are successful where they
turn around and they say these policies
of the last 20 years we don't want that
anymore and you're going to have America
going backward big time where you have
all of these big government Advocates
squashing freedom and authoritarians are
going to rise right to the top so what
happens then and that's the huge
parallel I see because I'm so tired
honestly of people saying America you
know America land to the free where
where is the freedom show me who those
Freedom Fighters are republicans in
Congress who sat on their asses for the
last two years while businesses were
shut down and said [ __ ] about it
where is it show me where those Freedom
Fighters are here because we can't be a
beacon for anybody unless we're doing it
ourselves and we're not doing it I think
what you're talking about is here in
America we have what is known as first
world problems yeah okay when uh a light
is being shined on what's what real
problems look like okay I mean we talk
about what's happening in Cuba trying to
people coming in terms of Miami here
right there what's going on in Iran I
think in America we've become complacent
fat lazy and what happens is your
comfort zone will kill you and when
you're comfortable and I remember I
interviewed a guy at the um the um
what's Gary
um who spoke at the Vault last year
Kasparov I he does the Oslo Freedom
forum and I interviewed the basically
the the a rat the host of the Iraqi
Daily Show it's like a comedian Iran he
goes I go what do you wish for the
people of Iraq it goes I wish I wish
that one day we could just sit there and
be fat and lazy and watch reality shows
like America that's how we'll know that
life is good but to this day we can't
just sit down turn on the TV you know be
fat lazy put a microwave meal in and
just watch reality TV show right Adam
let me just say this it's it's twofold
yes it's first four problems we're
spoiled we're lazy we're fat all those
things are true but it's also there are
people here Joy Behar wants to be told
what to do there is a there is a portion
of the population here that wants
systems of big government telling them
what to do they are uncomfortable with
their own personal decision making they
are uncomfortable with you making your
own decisions they're uncomfortable with
personal responsibility they are
comfortable with the values that built
this country and made it the land of the
free they are out to turn it around they
don't want America to be the land of the
free if they wanted that they wouldn't
have wanted you to have to get a
mandatory shot to walk into a restaurant
to eat a damn sandwich they don't want
that structure so when people say you
know there's a lot of my friend Jesse
Kelly on Twitter all the time it's
always like the Communist the Communists
and when he first started saying this I
was like oh this guy's out of his mind
now I'm like the Communist the Communist
because it's real there are people here
who want to undermine what makes this
country great so it's some of it is
first world problem sure the lazy the
complacent and some of it is a
deliberate effort by some to wreck this
country that has to be gutted out like a
cancer do you actually think they want
to wreck this country or they just don't
know better because I don't think anyone
that you just talk about literally wants
I think they want to change drastically
you remember Barack Obama's fundamental
transformation of the United States of
America well here it is here it is less
Freedom less personal responsibility
more authoritarians he was very
comfortable with that spread the wealth
when he said to Joe Plummer you know
when you spread your money around it's
good for everybody he meant it he meant
your money and your money and your money
just on his money just not his money
because he's fine and if you send the uh
immigrants over from Texas to Martha's
Vineyard just don't put him on his
backyard exactly so it was it was
separate set for rules for thee but not
for me and that's that's real so yes
they don't realize it's going to wreck
it because they're not these people
don't look at history and say oh look
every communist country oh it's been
destroyed that's interesting and they
think they're going to be the exception
you know in every communist country
there's the elite at the top that do
just fine they're like well it won't
Hollywood's like well we just haven't
done it the right way yet yeah that's
the constant thing we just haven't done
it the right way there's a lot of dumb
in there too I hate to say it but
liberalism can liberalism is not
grounded in reality it's not grounded in
fact and it's not grounded and
successful they're just not it's just
not it's not this stuff is not rooted in
in growth and opportunity it's not it's
it's rooted in authoritarianism it's
gonna it will ultimately wreck any
society if that's the path you follow
and and they say it right and then they
see it pat they see it just to add they
see the crime they see these things and
they ignore it they will please oh it's
not crime what are you talking what do
you mean you can't walk down the street
without getting mugged what are you
blind you're wearing blindflies yeah
what do you mean they change the
definition to inflation remember it's
they're changing the rules as they go so
that is on fire too I love it
but I'm gonna tell you um
this is what I'm convinced and I'm fully
convinced with this is bad ideas
eventually get exposed it's the best
thing about leaving this stuff on social
let people read it for themselves and do
research and eventually they get exposed
it happens all the time the best thing
that happened with social media the best
thing that happened with social media is
good idea bad idea doesn't matter
everybody got exposed good or bad idea
everybody got exposed if you think about
some of the guys in the Christian
Community the churches that were abusing
their members to make money guess what
happened to them they got exposed you
know that one Pastor that's sitting by
his plane and he's like let me pray for
you let me pray for you and the lady is
like no but let me ask you a question so
can you tell me why you need a fifth jet
because God wants me well listen that
guy got exposed so and then but at the
same time you see the rhetoric in Iran
when you see what these guys are this is
getting exposed the best thing with
social media we need more of these types
of things happening but while this is
going on watch what happened in Italy
different articles you want to give you
two different articles your video that
you just did about your response to
Andrew Tate it wasn't just a response to
Andrew Tate you were talking about
exposing everything yeah I mean I don't
know if that's what the kind of what you
were alluding to on that what but what
the Turkish prime minister had to say or
a member of parliament just basically
people are not done exactly listen
people are not dumb we are not dumb
sometimes people think everybody is dumb
people are not dumb they can sit there
and say that just doesn't a kid knows
when something doesn't make sense we are
born with no one when something just
doesn't make sense and they're going to
get exposed I want to read you two
articles okay so when it's from CNN one
is from Wall Street Journal then I want
you to watch your speech then I want you
to know how CNN responds back to it and
what they call this lady and see if you
think she does sound like somebody like
what they're calling her so I'll read
you the uh Wall Street Journal article
first okay Italian right-winger Georgia
Maloney wins election as economic clouds
gather Italians elected a right-wing
coalition to lead the country choosing
an untested leader who will confront
Europe's Gathering economic downturn and
energy crisis resulting from Russia's
invasion of Ukraine the incumbent right
when government will face difficult
decisions over how to protect Italian
households and businesses from Sky High
prices for electricity and natural gas
Italy's perilous public finances allow
limited scope for fiscal larges EU
government and have so far struggled to
agree on Collective intervention to
tackle energy costs aware that any
adverse reaction by Bond investors could
further hurt its Italy's economic
Outlook she has sought to reassure
financial markets that a government led
by Brothers of Italy would seek to
maintain fiscal discipline okay so
that's Wall Street Journal okay and the
way she's going to do it is uh that
constraints could leave limited scope
for the radical tax cuts that some in
the right-wing Coalition want okay
radical tax cuts okay now let me read
you CNN's you ready here's CNN same
story same day different uh uh Title
Here
Georgia Maloney claims Victor to become
Italy's most far-right prime minister
since Mussolini that's the title
Brothers of Italy's leader Georgia
Maloney have claimed victory in a
general election that seems to get uh
set and stall her as Italy's first
female prime minister leading the most
right-wing government since the fascist
era of Benito Mussolini keyword fascist
Maloney entered Italy is crowded a
political scene in 2006 and co-founded
the brothers of Italy in 2012 a party
where uh whose agendas rooted in a euro
skepticism and anti-immigration policy
in the last election in 2018 the party
won just by four and a half percent but
its popularity has soared in recent
years I wonder why underscoring Italy's
long-standing rejection of mainstream
politics a 45 year old mother from Rome
Maloney is deeply conservative openly
anti-lgbt and has threatened to play
same-sex Union which were legalized in
Italy in 2016 under review she has also
called abortion a tragedy Rising fears
for the future of women's rights in the
country so now for some of you guys that
haven't seen this video I put it on
Twitter yesterday in a you know from
another person that I just won't tell
you what happened to her clip in a span
of a day okay
18.3 million views in a day so just
listen to her first see if she sounds
reasonable you have to read the captions
to see what it says and then we'll tell
you how how you feel about her so
started from the beginning
is
perfect
ly
foreign
liberta
Perkins my
foreign
foreign
the left side and the other side works
if you saw that clip Jeff and you didn't
have no subtitles you don't know what
the hell she was saying see it they'll
take just her yelling and being
aggressive and be like look at how she
looks like a Mussolini look how she
looks like she's aggressive and look at
her anger you have no idea what the hell
she's saying and look at the message she
just said she's really woke I loved it
um I loved it and I I you know it's
interesting if I saw like the chain
people were responding and people were
saying can we get her over here
because and it's true if you if you look
at American politicians there's such a
diluted version of that like that that
looks like a real person with re that
looks authentic she cares what she's
saying it doesn't look like a program
robot coming out and saying a bunch of
talking points but I think this message
is terrifying to authoritarians it's
terrifying to folks on the left by the
way it's terrifying to folks on the left
in this country because they see the
Vigor with which a lot of people in
America responded to this and they're
like oh we don't want any of that this
look at what she's talking about God
country family Freedom the the power of
the individual she's talking about facts
she's talking about basic facts being
ignored that's a pivot to gender
identity she's talking about the fact
that we've just left that whole Realm of
the objective for this subjective
Whatever by which we can inject woke
politics into everything I thought it
was a very very powerful speech I think
it's this is what the left's been
battling in the United States for a long
time I mean you remember back to the
2008 presidential election them making
fun of people who clung who were
clinging to Bibles and their guns and
going after these concepts of individual
liberty and individual Freedom so I love
seeing it there I think it's important
to see it there but more than anything
Republicans in this country should be
embarrassed they should watch somebody
like that they should feel lazy they
should feel embarrassed humiliated and
somebody should get off their ass and
really start aren't talking because it's
not safe it's not safe like here like oh
freedom is safe here it's not it's not
safe here and we shouldn't be relying on
other countries and leadership in other
countries to say what we should be
saying and doing here I think the Santas
is the closest if I may is the closest
that we have to that type of leader I
think so the way he speaks the way he
doesn't care the way he doesn't hold
back the way he's just you know raw that
to me that's the female version of
Rhonda Sanders I mean she's that's
that's I'm a fan I love her she's
amazing the question you have to ask is
why it's a very basic question why did
that video go viral why it's a very
basic question why did 19 million people
in how long was it up by the way I'm
actually really curious why did 19 mil
from the moment the guy posted I'm gonna
go to the account was it two days back
yeah why did he this was posted 9 25 22
what's today's date and it was posted at
11 34 PM so it's not really two days
it's really it's really 36 out 35 hours
why has this thing gotten 19 million
views do you think because the people
want is it because 19 million people
hate it was because 19 million people
say dude this is kind of how I feel and
by the way it's 19 million people who
retweeted this out of the 19 million
people who retweeted how many of them
don't speak Italian
do you realize 19 million people
retweeted a message just to read
captions yeah and to feel her energy
knowing no clue I don't speak Italian
but I relate to this woman how do you
process this atom well
um I'm not ready to anoint her the best
president ever yeah I mean she's been in
office one day so let's just pump the
brakes
you know nobody here saying best
president ever exactly people are saying
a message that she gave nobody's totally
the president ever and that allows me to
speak about the message now clearly this
is someone who's passionate speaking
with conviction and people want
authenticity you can tell that she's
just like yo here's the freaking deal so
I respect that but I'm not going to rush
to judgment we're all familiar with the
Jeremy Lin analogy you just one way good
game or one good string of games doesn't
make a career so um everybody's nobody's
gonna judge her policies the message is
what we're talking about how do you feel
about her message I don't care what the
message she gave why is this message
doing so well in a time like this why is
her message why isn't Italy that was a
socialist country forcing everybody to
stay home this country that was going
through all the high taxes all the high
regulation all the high [ __ ] why is
it all of a sudden they want somebody
like her why is this message resonating
with the people well listen I watched a
few of her speeches not just this speech
okay so I'm not going to rush to
judgment and pretend I know all the
answers to freaking Italian politics
clearly she speaks with authority and
with conviction and respect to her for
that and respect to her for being the
first female prime minister in the
history of Italy so respect and if you
go through her speeches she says things
like world problems require everyone's
contribution respect mutual respect for
people democratic system I'd look to
unite not divide so all these are all
great talking points the flip side is
she's anti-lgbt so there's going to be
people talking about that's literally
The Stance of their party what is it
what does that mean how does that
manifest no because people are called
anti-lgbt here in the United States
because they don't want people who
identify as a certain gender to be able
to use her party agenda is rooted is
rooted in anti-immigration
what I'm saying is I don't even trust
that description because they say
anti-immigrant if somebody wants to have
a secure board yeah so I just don't
trust I'm okay with it I'm just I get it
yeah
not against you I'm saying I'm just
genuinely curious I'm just giving you
both sides of the equation I mean just
I'm not saying that I'm ready to anoint
her as the best leader ever just clearly
she's she's been getting a lot of
eyeballs and that's great just from that
speech she's pro-family and she's tired
of you know X or Y or Z or male she
she's tired of the Walk [ __ ] that's what
I got from that I don't know okay so let
me tell you New York Times an article
came out about her saying she's against
gay couples adopting kids okay okay so
she's against gay couples adopting kids
that is something she's not comfortable
with
if that's anti-lgbt then that's her
position she's not for gay couples uh
adopting a kid but he's also threatened
basically to uh do away with same-sex
marriages I don't this is not anything I
really am like obsessed with at all I'm
not gay this is not something that I
believe in but if people want to get
married that's on them exactly 100 judge
you but I'm just letting you know what
she's stands for but the the bigger
message here and this kind of will
Circle back to what our friend said in
2011 about being a financial Speculator
is she said it multiple times that I
want people to be an individual not a
number right and uh basically she's
calling out what she calls as us being
consumers or just labeled as consumers
by these massive conglomerates and
basically not being at the whim of
financial speculators so I'm interested
to see what she does with the Italian
economy because I've been to Italy and
like the whole knock on Italy is the the
the northern half of the country
basically supports the whole Southern
half of the country the whole Southern
half of the country is basically just on
perennial vacation they don't pay taxes
they're just getting
you know plus she's got an uphill
challenge you know Pat can speak to this
all day the mafia still controls a bunch
of stuff in Italy taxes this kind of
stuff so
awesome amazing speech you know Oscar
amazing great gold medal I'd like to see
what actually she does before I anoint
her the queen care less about what she
does let me let me tell you why I'm
processing this I care less about what
she does since two since they started
their party people know what she stands
for it's not like it's a new thing like
she's been coming up since 2006 when she
hit the political scene so since 2000
for example people are going to know if
let's just say Jedediah runs in 10 years
right yeah let's just say she does I
mean it's a realistic it's a candidate
it's a realistic candidate we're talking
to today it does something 10 years from
now could happen if she does in 10 years
people gonna know her stance since the
meeting with Hillary Clinton they're
gonna sit there and say okay this is
what she stood for and they're not gonna
say all of a sudden Jedediah is this to
you and I we've not seen her because
we're not in Italy you're right we're
not part of Italian politics but for a
person a woman to win prime minister
first ever to win this tells you the
fascists that they're talking about
about the Republicans they're talking
about they don't care if the prime
minister is a man or a woman but they
care that the values and principles that
that they believe in is protected by a
leader they don't look at her as a woman
I don't look at her as a woman I look at
her as a leader of course she's a mother
she's a Christian she's got all this
stuff Christian but I look at her as a
voice as a leader and and the only thing
you have to look at is why is this
message resonating today with the
Italian people are they sick of what
happened the last two and a half years
that they vote for somebody to like this
salute more power to the people of Italy
how long do how long is there a term for
for those typos I didn't tell you as you
know Ty I'm looking okay because I'm
curious like is it like five years is it
ten like how how long was the last prime
minister in there
I mean I think your question about why
it resonates I think it resonates
because there's a huge void of this
there's a void of somebody who will do
this it takes a lot of courage and guts
to do this to say these things it
resonates with people in Italy because
all of those backward policies which by
the way we're now trying to Institute in
the United States buried all of the
Italian people and they're like no I'm
sorry I want to be able to feed my
family I'm not interested in this
nonsense that's why it resonated with
them it resonated with people in
countries like the United States of
America because we're going the wrong
way and we're trying to say hold on a
second we don't we do we really need to
be buried to wake up and the reason I
brought up that point to you Adam was
not to pick on you for saying anti-algae
btq and all that the reason I brought
that up is because it actually really is
an important political point which is
that the left often controls language so
this is a Christian instead of calling
her auntie L LBGTQ why don't you call
her pro-traditional family why don't you
call her Pro she's religious she does
doesn't believe in same-sex marriage
that's not a reason to she's not anti
she's pro-something so when we do that
anti-immigrant why because you want to
secure borders so I I just I encourage
people to always just not fall into that
trap
um now I don't know the specificity of
her policy on this that but just be
cautionary about being these labels that
they throw out there you know it's the
same as oh racist bigot anti you know
they throw these labels out when they
want to just have somebody look like a
bigot instead you know she has her own
set of values she has her own set of
things she believes and she's really
they're people religious all over the
United States by the way who don't
believe in same-sex marriage not because
they hate gay people but because they're
religious and that's they're looking at
the Bible they're not bigots so just be
careful with accepting the language of
the left because it's meant to
stigmatize I agree I agree phenomenal
this was great to you know see her views
and folks if you're listening to this
and you uh uh you know agree with the
audience that's response be curious to
know how many guys listen to her message
and say you know what I was impressed by
give it a thumbs up if you're like yeah
whatever I'm not real really the message
didn't do anything for me give us a
thumbs down we actually wouldn't mind
seeing put a poll down there if you can
Tyler I'd be curious on how the audience
is receiving her message the next thing
I want to talk to you guys about is this
whole nuclear conversation and if it
happens how ugly could it get I got a
few notes here that I want us to get
into but before we do that let me give a
quick shout out to today's sponsor of
this podcast which is Aura couple things
I want you to know in regards to Aura
they're one of the top identity theft
companies in America and we've chosen to
partner with these guys for a couple
different reasons number one is you know
a 1.5 million identity theft scenarios
took place last year in America you
ready for this for a total of 52 billion
dollars let me say this one more time 52
billion dollars so a lot of times before
this happens to you don't think it's
going to happen to you every 14 seconds
there's a new victim on top of it in the
history of America cyber crime is
officially exceeded home robbery it's
officially number one that this happens
we had one one of our guys take Aura
Aaron went up there and says let me see
what Aura can test for myself over 40
different of his passwords were public
in the dark web over 40 different
passwords some of you guys may have
passwords I've gone through this before
if you haven't gone through it if it's
very ugly whether it's social security
credit cards any of that stuff so you
know if you haven't done that I suggest
you look into these guys what Aura does
is they monitor the dark web for your
emails passwords Social Security numbers
and sends alerts to you right to your
phone and email when it comes to fraud
every second matters connect your credit
card bank accounts again notified of any
changes up to four times faster than
aura's competitors their VPN allows you
to stay anonymous online by keeping your
browsing history and personal
information safe and encrypted and their
anti-virus software will block malware
and viruses before they infect your
devices so having said that protect
yourself
protect you and your family from
America's fastest growing crime try Aura
free for two weeks and see if any of you
or your family's personal information
has been compromised you can start your
14-day trial at aura.com forward slash
pbd once again aura.com forward slash
pbd Aura spelled a u r a.com forward
slash pbd free 14-day trial go take
advantage and we're going to put the
link below so for people to be able to
find it as well so having said that
let's let's talk about this story of a
nuclear bombs and this is from CBS by
the way it's not like it's a blog or
somebody that just wrote it for the heck
of it CBS writes this article okay and
the title reads nuclear war between us
and Russia would kill more than 5
billion people just from starvation's
fine uh study fines even a relatively
small nuclear conflict such as one
between India and Pakistan would be
devastating a week-long nuclear war
involving 100 weapons and the release of
5G 5tg about 11 billion pounds of suit
would kill 27 million people directly
the study said after two years the
international trade at a halt of 34.7
degrees uh Fahrenheit temperature
dropped the famine it creates would kill
255 million people assuming that the
rest of the population got the minimum
food need to needed to survive about
1999 calories per capita per day the
largest scenario examine a week-long war
involving 4 400 weapons 150 TG 330.6
billion pounds of suit
such as one that would occur between the
U.S its allies and Russia would kill 360
million people directly and more than 5
billion people from starvation and when
you hear a story like this we had Peter
uh Dr Peter dry here Peter Peter pry
here twice in one month first time we
ever did that with a guest he came in
here we talked about new he was one of
the leading uh voices in the world
leading expert voices in the world in
weapons of mass destruction nuclear
bombs he just died a month ago by the
way you know it rest in peace he died a
month ago we had him four or five months
ago
you know
uh Putin making the prediction on a
nuclear weapon that if you do this you
know we're gonna do this and then U.S
warns Putin of catastrophic consequences
of nuclear weapons are used in UK or
Ukraine this is a Reuters Story the US
would respond decisively 20 rushing use
of nuclear weapons against Ukraine and I
spelled out to Moscow the catastrophic
consequences it would face U.S national
security adviser Jake Sullivan on said
on Sunday
etc etc okay
what is the likelihood for any one of
you you know percentage-wise what is the
likelihood that Putin uses a nuclear
weapon against Ukraine at this point
what do you think
what do you think it is
let's just hope that it's freaking very
low Tyler where are you at what do you
think it is with Putin using nuclear
weapons against Ukraine we keep sending
Ukraine 50 60 70 billion dollars I think
the percentage gets higher and higher
and higher every day again we're talking
about Iran right and the protests in
Iran and the people standing up for
freedom and actually something that
could be pivotal in not only the Middle
East but the world right if they were to
overthrow the government this could
fundamentally reshape the Middle East in
the world yet we have no concern about
it right we want to send off 50 60 70
billion dollars and sit there and kick
Vladimir Putin until he turns around and
he punches us what do you think is going
to happen like this is our fault I think
we need to get out of Ukraine the idea
that Ukraine was going to then move or
excuse me that Russia was then going to
move into Poland and totally reform the
USSR is absurd he knows he doesn't have
the power to do that he knows exactly
what would happen if he did try to do
that he wanted to take over Ukraine
because we kept pushing to put NATO uh
in Ukraine have Ukraine become a part of
NATO and put the U.S military nuclear
weapons at his doorstep and he knows
better than that
um I think the chances of him using
nukes get higher and higher and higher
every day is it a one percent is it at
five percent is it a ten percent what do
you think I don't think it's a
full-scale nuclear weapon I think it's a
tactile but I think it's at 15 but I
don't know there's part of what I what
you're saying that I agree with like
we're pushing uh Putin to the edge and
I've been saying this for months now
we've got to get this guy an off ramp if
there's anything that he demands it's
respect if you're feeling disrespected
and you're backed against the wall you
know you're gonna lash out like a you
know scared animal uh but I don't agree
with you Tyler on what is he gonna
invade Poland it's like there's is a
reason that freaking Finland who has
been basically you know abstaining from
being a part of NATO for 50 years is
like yeah we're gonna join now because
they share a 400 mile border with Russia
so if they can just walk into Ukraine
next thing you know they're walking into
Finland next thing you know walking to
Poland these are legitimate concerns
from bordering countries so I do trust
that our government knows what they're
doing in relation to Ukraine and Russia
that's fine you can be on the other side
of the table that's good but I think
Anthony blinken who's basically running
the show over there is a very competent
individual he just yeah he's the joke I
mean that's great this is why we're in
[ __ ] America that you can have your
opinion you can have that proud boy
opinion I can have my soy boy opinion we
can meet in the middle it's all good but
I do think that the world is basically
spoken that a Madman just can't just
walk into other people's countries and
redefine borders when they just
magically become a Madman why was he not
a Madman in 2016.
let's just say a power hungry guy let's
just say it like that I know I know that
your side wants to you know Advocate
Putin that's your guy you kind of have a
poster about his wall I get with the
at-home however why do you think he
didn't do this in 2016. what was the
first thing that Donald Trump wanted to
do he wanted to abolish NATO what was
the point of NATO was to keep the USSR
in check where's the USSR they haven't
existed since Ronald Reagan the first
thing Trump wanted to do was abolish
NATO and that's what kept Vladimir Putin
at Bay yeah because if somebody is going
to abolish NATO you're just gonna let
them do what they want to do What's the
phrase if your enemy is basically
shooting himself in the foot go ahead
and shoot yourself let him shoot
themselves in the foot of course if the
president United States is talking about
abandoning NATO if you're Putin you're
like have at it why do I need to do
anything to to make this happen you're
going to talk about it doing anyway and
there's a high likelihood that if Trump
was re-elected he'd be pushing more and
more and more to get out of NATO right
so I don't I don't agree with this
presumption that if Trump was there then
who knows what happened with Putin
Putin's been basically been calculated
this entire time if there's anything you
want to say about Putin is it is
calculated so maybe I misspoke about the
madman thing but the guy could turn into
a [ __ ] madman and basically we don't
give him an offer I think the percentage
is kind of in the low but uh but like I
don't know if you guys saw the interview
with Jordan Peterson with Piers Morgan
and I mean he it was scary as [ __ ]
because he even asked Jordan Pearson he
goes he probably could I mean like those
tactical little dirty nukes bro it's not
like a missile and it just it's
dangerous bro I don't know and
especially like this Winter's coming
he's in charge of what all all the you
know who I forgot the quote was
something about you could heal controls
the money isn't in power it's a person
that controls all the like you know the
the food and the and the supplies and
[ __ ] it's going to be a really really
bad winter for Europe because in dude on
time right now they're gonna keep
pushing him and keep pushing him and
keep pushing him he could do it I would
say it's at like a 15 to 20 why didn't
we have the same reaction when Putin
invaded Crimea
why didn't we have the same reaction oh
my God he's going to reform the USSR why
haven't all all of a sudden now it's
Ukraine that he invades Ukraine that
he's going to reform the USSR Obama sat
back he said give me space I'll give you
what you want and he walked into [ __ ]
Crimea and nobody cared
six people died in Crimea that was it
and he took it over and like
fundamentally not much has changed but
now all of a sudden he wants to walk
into Ukraine and everybody loses their
mind so we're sitting essentially what's
your point that we should do nothing in
Ukraine and just let us know he's got to
do it totally disagree the Obama
Doctrine I totally disagree that was
done with an interview with Barack Obama
in like 2014 Obama said we have no
fundamental interest in Ukraine it
serves us no purpose he said this out
loud he said we have no interest in
defending Ukraine because it doesn't
serve us a purpose again it was the
third most corrupt country in the world
it still is an exceptionally corrupt
country
and all we're doing is pissing off
Vladimir Putin losing money losing arms
getting to a point where we can't defend
ourselves and we're pushing him into the
arms of Xi Jinping who is an actual real
threat Vladimir Putin is a bully he's
nothing more than an annoyance if we
wanted to flatten Russia we could do it
quick they also have more nuclear
weapons than us so no I mean that you're
kind of speaking out of both sides of
your mouth you can't like you
so what's your ultimate point that we
should not be in Ukraine whatsoever and
we should just let Putin push her on his
weight and just start invading countries
left and right because after Ukraine how
do you know it doesn't go into Finland
there's a [ __ ] reason that Finland
after 50 years
join NATO so if you if you listen the
the Pres the prime minister of Finland
just spoke out against this he went on
to Fareed Zakaria who's a very credible
news source and he's like yeah I've been
meeting with Putin for years and years
and years I've never seen him like this
and he asked a very specific question he
goes what effect did kovid do you think
have on Putin and he goes I think he's
been isolated by his Palace in his
Palace all by himself and he's kind of
going stir crazy and the madman
Tendencies are coming out if you're by
yourself and nobody's around you giving
you influence nobody's talking sense to
you who knows what he's going to do
right now so if you're the world and
you're looking back and you're seeing a
strong man walk into a country and start
taking it over it's a little bit
different than Ukraine I'm sorry than
Crimea when you walk into Kiev and you
start basically killing innocent people
in nurseries and and old age homes it's
a little bit different than six people
being killed in Crimea it's a little bit
different so if you don't stand up to
Putin now and you just let him do this
what you you're clearly advocating
what's next so no I'm an advocate of
standing our ground the world standing
the ground the EU standing in the ground
saying No this is completely
unacceptable to just start recreating
borders I'm not an advocate of that are
you
well that's what we're doing currently
it feels like in the U.S that the the
same Administration that wants to defend
Ukraine's border doesn't want to defend
the southern border of the United States
so that's that's a totally different
concept now you're going on to a
different thing I'm asking why with why
is it our business though Adam I wanna I
wanna know because here's the thing the
number is actually I think lower I think
it's probably right now at about a five
percent but Tyler's right in my opinion
I do think that when you poke the bear
and poke the bear and poke the bear that
number is gonna rise so my my question
is why has this become the new cause
here in America why are we sending money
my opinion is we should not be sending a
dime to Ukraine what is the
justification for that it is a deeply
deeply corrupt government that has been
elevated by most of the hard left in
this country as another America they
present it as if it's this great
Democratic Republic it is not it is not
and if the if the new if the new uh
Mantra here is that we need to intervene
every time Putin does something or every
time to what end so I'm just trying to
figure out the long-term strategy of
that is that that we get involved and
send financial and otherwise assistance
to every country when this happens why
is Ukraine different why did isn't it
interesting to everybody that the entire
American Media jumped on board with this
talking point from the get-go the entire
American Media on the left who is
largely inter non-interventionists at
their core why are they suddenly so
passionate about us sending a ton of
money to Ukraine and why has zelenski
become this I mean you see him as if
he's The Rock's the second coming of
Christ so I I find that highly
suspicious in a government that's deeply
deeply corrupt again this is not America
number two and by a lot of people who
generally speaking are very much stay
out of it unless they come at us it's
none of our business stay out of it that
suddenly have this heavily
interventionist approach I find it all
highly suspicious I don't think we
should at all you bring up some very
valid points right there and if it was
just the U.S that was basically funding
this operation I would have legitimate
questions as to what's going on but when
the entire EU and a NATO who's on that
side of the world is basically saying
yeah we're on team Ukraine yeah that's
kind of makes a little bit more sense to
me so if it was just the United States
clearly hear you on that but I don't
know something about what's the
Strategic interest for us though in
getting involved in Ukraine in
particular and is there going to be a
strategic interest in getting involved
in Finland in every area that Putin
decides to or not to touch what is the
Strategic American interest in doing
that yeah I mean that's something that
you should ask Anthony blinken but well
I don't need to ask Anthony Blakely
because it doesn't exist so your
business so the question I have is
you're just okay with strong men
basically recreating borders no that I
mean listen that's a legitimate question
though Jed no I mean do I love Putin no
am I a Putin fan do I wear a Putin shirt
no I don't but there has to be a reason
for involvement if you're going to send
first of all this country is broke we
are broke the people of this country are
broke there is no justification for
sending money out unless there's a
strategic interest for the United States
you know this whole America First we're
done we're people are struggling here
they can't put food on their table the
gas prices this that everybody wants to
complain about that and then it's like
oh let's send more money if we are going
to send our money out and we are going
to poke the bear over there which we are
doing and we are going to to invite a
higher level of risk assessment for
people in the United States with every
move we make than their damn water be
damn well better be uh strategic
interest that can be delineated that's
clear and a long-term plan I don't see
either of those things and I see a
deeply corrupt government that we're
rushing to defend with no justification
so my 100 vote is stay out of it that
doesn't mean I endorse Putin that means
that not not every instance will warrant
United States intervention and justify
that and in this case it does not I'm
totally okay with being
non-interventionalist hundred percent I
mean that money is being yeah but it's a
different thing this is a proxy war this
isn't [ __ ] Vietnam this isn't the
disaster that happened in Iraq or
Afghanistan if anything we've learned
our lesson that we can't send our troops
into these countries to try to make a
difference why are we sending our money
well because that's basically the what
we have the resources that we don't do
of course we do we don't have it we just
talked about the debt we don't have it
people we don't have that money to spend
that's extra we don't have that money we
we could we could easily Tyler brings up
the Border everybody wants to laugh
about that but we can easily take that
money and put it toward defending our
own borders and where we have a flood of
dangerous drug cartels that are coming
across the Texas border every day nobody
seems to care about take that money that
we're sending over to Ukraine and
actually do something to protect our own
border from this influx of Horror that's
affecting you know a human trafficking
surge that's a disaster we have plenty
of things that that money needs to go to
that it's currently being sent to
Ukraine where there is no strategic
interest so I think it's no-brainer and
I think there is something deeply
corrupt going on
um at the high government level that is
that is then filtering out two media
that is encouraging this and it's very
dangerous in practice mentioned that
article about uh us this one is from
Reuters where U.S warns Putin of
catastrophic consequences of nuclear
weapon used in Crane and U.S would
respond decisively to any Russian use
what does that mean respond decisively
you're going to enter a war with Russia
now over Ukraine this is utterly insane
this is we are now in insane Turf um and
it just it's it's
it's wakadoo well and Adam my point with
Crimea only six people died so they
estimate 80 000 Russians have been
killed in this conflict how many do you
think would have died if the United
States wasn't sending weapons money
ammunition funding arming to the
Ukrainian Army
yeah well I mean if you want to know a
larger strategy the United States
probably has is they would love to see
Putin out of office and if you're seeing
what's happening right now in Russia and
then you just what called up that 300
000 reservists
people are protesting okay so you have a
strong man in Russia they don't even
have it's not even oligarchy it's a
freaking thugocracy okay it's him and
his thugs basically just siphoning off
money for themselves and just doing what
they want in the country and I think at
the at the end of the day United States
this is not something that we stand for
now we can kind of go about different
you know ways of basically dealing with
him well who's right who's wrong but if
in terms of values and principles of
what we stand for in America Russia and
Putin is not it so neither is what's
going on Andre zielinski in Ukraine
though that's the thing it's been
glorified it's been twisted and
destroyed and you're not wrong about
that that's not for that either so why
we don't stand for any of it so stay out
of it you know like and and this
government stays out plenty remember the
Iranian revolutions during the Obama
years we stayed out of that why people
were saying oh that they're in the
streets they're talking about Freedom
they're talking about Freedom they need
help they need help and they're like no
no no no no let's not even get involved
in there so this this something this is
something deeply corrupt and political
because if we were going to get involved
that's internal was there a proxy war
that we could have fight in Iran but but
there's nobody there's nobody to fund
but how are we gonna fund people right
but there was not even but it was but a
call for that by the by the the hard
left in this country that's now putting
zielinski on posters outside it's like
you got to have you know on Twitter it's
like you've got your your gender
pronouns and then you've got your
Ukrainian flag and you've got a big
picture of zelenski why that's that
tells you there's something deeply
disturbing going on here if you if you
can't outline the Strategic interest for
the United States and it's just well
Putin is bad Putin is bad what's going
on in Ukraine under a deeply corrupt
government is bad it's none of our
business
then you want to weigh in
I um
I was lost at Ukraine
zielinski
with the whole you know Biden what was
that was that uh that interview where he
was sitting there with barisma his son
everything maybe they just say Hey
listen keep sending us money we have a
bunch of evidence we won't say [ __ ] we
won't yeah just keep helping I said yo
we're up to what 80 billion how much
money have we given them it's it's 50 or
60. okay listen we're gonna keep going
we're paying for it what and I agree
what is the end goal what are we getting
from I know they're rich and a bunch of
you know they have like you know uh
minerals and they have all that stuff
are we getting any of that well we're
helping them but there is a there is a
reason that we don't know and I would I
mean I think it's corrupt 100 I'm I'm
with her here's my biggest concern let
me just say what my biggest concern is
so
um
there are certain stories we won't know
for a long time like We're Not Gonna
Know Why such a massive support for
Ukraine with Biden and his son Hunter
and the dealings with you we're not
going to know that for maybe 20 30 years
like the real story things may come out
of the sentence gets elected and maybe
some kind of you put some kind of
Investigation to go look it up fine but
you're going to see a movie 30 years
from now we're all going to be in our
70s and we're going to sit down did you
see that new movie starring you know
Ryan Gosling you know his grandson you
know whatever
and we're going to say wow remember that
one time in the podcast in 2022 When We
Were Young we were talking about it and
we're going to laugh and crack up I'm
going to say damn that's pretty dark on
what happened so stay tuned for that on
what happened there aside from that
um my biggest concern is you know
there's certain again I've said this
certain people that say they're going to
do something if you if you take it
lightly and then they do it a lot of
people get hurt
and you know when you're looking like
right now Azerbaijan Armenia you know
China Taiwan Russia Ukraine if it all it
takes is one all it takes is one moment
for Putin to wake up and say you guys
don't believe I'm real no problem boom
here's Ukraine then you have to respond
right
so you we have to respond because we're
in too deep then if we do respond then
what happens okay today if you talk to
folks in Europe they'll tell you
electricity bill is up uh 80 90 okay you
know the whole concept of winter is
coming winter is coming for them like
right now how many people in the world
you think are worried about the
hurricane in Florida only people living
in Florida right okay nobody else but no
one around the country is gonna say hey
what's going on with the hurricane
but but if you if you're living in
Ukraine if you're living in Russia if
you're living in Europe if you're living
in those places you're sitting there
saying I hope something doesn't tick the
sky off to go to the next side that's
all I'm saying if they push them to that
point we don't know why Biden is so
protective about it somebody like you
know you see this in movies or scenes
where somebody's overprotective about a
personality you know in the next thing
oh they're dating that's why you know
nobody puts baby in the corner they're
dating there's a baby she's pregnant
like even the movie Dirty Dancing
there's something that why is Biden so
protective of Ukraine weird someone's
pregnant someone's got a baby you don't
put baby Ukraine in the corner let me
ask you a legitimate question don't you
think that the powers that be whether
you're Secretary of State you're the you
know the defense National Defense
generals don't you think legitimate
question they've sat in a room already
gone gone through all these War Games
don't you think that's happened yeah
you'd be naive if you say no to that
clearly they've had these discussions
clearly NATO's had these discussions how
much do we want to push them clearly
they've already over thought yes but
what does that mean to does that mean
that they're right of course they've had
the discussions listen you know for
example it's like saying clearly you
have to tell me that the coaches of the
Lakers know Shaq's free throw is an
issue you have to know clearly they're
practicing it so clearly they know that
Dwight Howard only has one move to dunk
and they have to work on us clearly the
coaches know this clearly the coaches do
know that clearly they know that but the
wrong strategy still could lose and many
people in the perfect how many times
have you watched a professional you know
Super Bowl in a professional coach
making 10 million dollars a year makes
one bad call and it constantly we've
seen it so what makes you think
professionals don't make a bad call this
doesn't mean blinking is a bulletproof
guy with the best strategies of the
world and he's a second coming of Sun
Tzu and he's got all the best strategies
he's going to write a Art of War part
two by blinking oh he's the one that's
gonna no so it just means sometimes you
got badly leaders in place that they're
over their head and there are certain
decisions that they shouldn't be making
and by the way we're going to find that
very soon all I'm saying is I'll talk to
you from the economy standpoint
the Market's already going to go down
the next two and a half years until you
know by the way the only thing like
midterms that the Republicans when I see
the market spiking in uh right after
election so if you look at whatever
election falls on what day what day is
it on in uh November midterms is one
November uh Tyler is it the second
November 7th okay November 7th you vote
on the 22nd 100 expect November 8th for
the market to go up okay November 8th
expect the market to go up on November
8th okay if they win Congress if they
have control of if there's any kind of
thing to have control Market's going to
go up if it doesn't Mark is going to
keep going down but if Putin does attack
Ukraine with nuclear weapons that will
go down to 15 to 18 000 now 18 000. that
will go to 15 to 18 now if that happens
the level of panic and the fear selling
will be record breaking at the highest
level if it goes to that point if it
does okay you're hoping it doesn't
happen at this point he's losing people
leaving this country they're going to
other countries they don't he's losing
people right now he's asked 300 000
people who are civilians who are former
vests to come and serve like dude I
don't want to do this but babe you're 42
years old what are you doing you don't
shouldn't know that he's what do you
want me to do Putin's asking me to do it
people are in a very civil unrest over
there but if this next move happens by
him to show strength I think things will
move very very rapidly and uh you know I
I would be much more for a different
your friend said something the other day
where it's you know we're over here I
didn't you know a couple of guys one
guy's like well you know what do you
want him to do I'm like look you can you
have to figure out a more diplomatic way
of handling certain situations if you
don't it leads to war the diplomas
diplomacy takes place here so someone's
got to get in there and figure out a way
to get closer to get this man to not
make that kind of dramatic decision
remember when they had talks in March
and they scrapped him we we were right
there we were about to have diplomacy
yeah they scrapped it you know why I
think we're so maybe this is you know
like you said years down the road we're
gonna find out like maybe don't put baby
in the corner I guarantee you Hunter
Biden probably was there and got high
and left the laptop
and now we're like we gotta give them as
much money as we can don't there's
something something
20 years like you said we're gonna be
like oh that's what it was it could be
something like that because we've lifted
them up you said it remember that month
everything was Ukraine the flag people
had no idea what the hell was going on
zelinski was an actor now he's all of a
sudden like it's like it's like this you
know I've ran sales offices for a long
time and all of a sudden I'll see one
guy defend a girl in the office yeah
and then two months later that's my
girlfriend oh I knew it yeah I I got it
got you maybe Ukraine's Biden's
girlfriend something I don't know what's
going on I don't know something's going
on We're Not Gonna Know for a minute but
it is what it is listen the good news is
Apple begins making the iPhone in India
marking a big shift in its manufacturing
strategy Apple said Monday it's
assembling it's Flagship iPhone 14 in
India and the US technology giant looks
to shift some production away from China
I think we read the story a couple weeks
ago JPMorgan analyst said in a note this
month that Apple will move five percent
of its production over to India by late
2022 Apple could make 25 of its iPhones
by 2025 in India this is phenomenal I'm
gonna keep giving love to India India is
the number one threat to China China
does not like India they don't like the
fact that the average age in India is 28
years old versus the average age in
China is 38 close to 39 years old and
they have the same amount of population
and they're not afraid of China and the
Prime Minister banned 100 apps of China
in India Tick Tock is not available in
India wow these are all great things
that's going on and by the way the fact
that Mark benihoff gets up there and
says you know if you want to pull up the
mark benihoff story from Salesforce and
he says uh uh uh Mark Benny have
threatens to pull company from that's
that's a completely different thing
because it's it's a different place but
it goes back to Adam throwing us off but
you know what I love seeing Indiana I
love seeing India doing what they're
doing with production I love China being
afraid of India I love seeing them
picking up more contracts I hope they
continue to do what they're doing with
uh that part now let's talk about
British pound just plunged to an
all-time low against the U.S dollar
here's what happened and what it means
okay it's on page nine if you want to go
to it this is actually a pretty big deal
because everything they're buying on
Imports about to go up so the pound
plunge uh plunged to an all-time low of
um
1.035 against the US Dollar on Monday as
Traders bet that looming tax cut could
fuel inflation prompt faster interest
rate hikes and undermine Britain's
already shaky economy Chancellor kawasi
quarteng said Friday that he intends to
scrap Britain's top income tax rate of
45 percent to to scrap Nix a scheduled
rise in the national insurance rate and
abolished the stamp Duty on property
purchase of under 250 000 his tax cut
plan is aimed at boosting the ailing UK
economy and reducing the risk of severe
recession however it sparked fear of
faster price increases government debt
that's out of control and a worse
downturn and a weaker pound will make
Imports more expensive do you remember
the when everybody used to say with the
pound is the pound is two times the US
dollar look at this right here zoom in a
little bit zoom in a little bit zoom in
a little bit go to go to 2008 or 2009
whatever that is what is that so a
little bit more a little bit more a
little bit more 2007 2008. it was just
so you know at the highest it was 2.11
to the dollar and it dropped to 1.035
they're sitting there saying do you know
what this means though like what you
were buying your old money can't buy
what it was buying wow so say you're
sitting on 250 000 to buy a house that's
worth two hundred fifty thousand dollars
but then it drops from two to one to one
that means you now need five hundred
thousand dollars okay to buy the same
thing you were gonna buy import coming
in this is a real issue in Ukraine in
the UK and you so Pat what would you
like investment wise remember like that
guy that that said opportunity wise and
all that stuff what kind of opportunity
would you say like especially when
something like that happening is it like
buying stuff in in Europe what would be
like one of the things that somebody
could do to take advantage of this type
of situation I I don't take my advice on
this I love your advice I I would buy
the pound seriously I would buy the
pound because look at the pound over the
last 50 years 60 years look at the pound
yep you know it's generally Buck 50 to
the US dollar okay so maybe it takes a
hit for the next year two years and then
goes back to Buck fifth you're gonna
make fifty percent but that's again the
I'm purely speculating what I would do
that's my money you do you can go buy to
two men if you want to go buy some pesos
I'm just saying if it's at a one to one
it may not be a bad time to buy some
some yeah so what's your strategy with
pesos just move to the UK bro move the
UK I will say this um you know we get
fixated on what's going on in the
American economy clearly we're here in
America we're pro-america we want us our
you know we want to prosper and do all
that housing market stock market I think
it it just it just gives a clearer
perspective like
everyone's dealing with some [ __ ] right
now since covet okay point to a country
that's thriving right now I guess you
know China is the only country that had
a positive GDP in 2021 but a lot of
countries especially bigger ones you
know more prominent countries everyone's
dealing with economic issues right now
since covet okay all the money and the
inflation the printing and everything
that Dave Ramsey talked about
um so everyone's kind of looking for
stability in their life you know and
like what Jed talked about it starts
within your own individual situation
your personal responsibility uh because
there's so much craziness going on in
the world right now you know if you
would have told us a few years ago that
the pound is equal to the dollar would
be like what the hell are you talking
about I don't believe you the Euro just
went below the dollar a few months ago
that never yeah the world is changing so
um you know we kind of [ __ ] on what's
happening in the US economy but from a
global macro perspective we're doing all
right the dollar is pretty strong right
now but you know focus on what you can
control not basically what's happening
in the in total macro global economy got
you so with that being said that whole
last go by the pound like when in here
and flew and it went through her but I
feel good like I feel like what you're
talking about we have to sit down for at
least you look like a broker from Golden
yeah exactly today today you should do a
skit saying so you know as a Goldman
Sachs advisor I'd like to give you some
counsel on what to do with your
Investments and you say that too when
you put that hat on the screen let's see
if the Hat makes it like when you put
that without trying to be dorky they're
like I'm cool you look like you just got
drafted first round of the NBA right
there let's put the look right there I
love this hat
so look man I got a couple last things
here before we wrap up with nine minutes
before I get on this stream team call uh
uh a question just a crazy question for
you guys crazy question for you guys I'm
curious to know what you think about
this what similarities do the Kennedys
and the trumps have together what
similarities do those two families have
to get out of curiosity what what
similarities do Trump by the way
politically Republican Democrat but what
do those two families have in common
they look good what else I would say
they both really love the country like
genuinely have a love for the country I
agree okay I can't say I don't think
about the bushes or the clintons or I
agree Pat and I think we talked about
this last our last podcast I love them
hate them I don't care watch go on
YouTube YouTube
um Donald Trump 90s Lettermen everything
every single time he was on I love
America I love the he was he was Pro
pro-american I think uh Tyler just
killed he the the Kennedys were willing
to die for it what else do you think
they had I think they both have uh uh
generational Legacy such going on you
know it started with Joseph Kennedy down
to JFK and Bobby and Ted Kennedy and now
their kids are involved and obviously if
you start with what Fred Trump what was
the what was the father and basically
Donald and and obviously the kids that
are going on now and everything that
theyvan go and die so there's like you
know uh which the same thing you can
kind of say for the bushes
um but basically there's a there's a
deeper perspective of familial
involvement in macroeconomics why were
so many political Elites why did they
want to get rid of both families
well they're disruptors
okay so so we just got to the point
right now so both of them are disruptors
yeah they like didn't want war what what
else neither one of them wanted War what
else
um what else you're calling out the uh
The Establishment The Establishment
right what else they were they were for
the most part United Okay as a family
what else
unpredictable unpredictable what else
those two families the uh the head of
the family whether it's JFK or uh Trump
they're sleeping with women they're
sleeping with a lot of women that's
exactly
you Stormy Daniels or Marilyn Monroe
Monroe I would say Marilyn over stormy
any day of the week yeah oh 100 I think
the biggest thing has to be going
against the establishment right
establishment military establishment
agencies
Etc industrial complex the CIA the FBI
oh yeah yeah that's an interesting thing
on why those two families got targeted
where you know you eventually kind of
want both families to go away hey you
kind of not letting us do what we're
doing we don't like you just be quiet
leave us alone do you know kind of do
goals where we're back in the days
assassination was a little bit different
to do because you didn't have the whole
social media and all this stuff going on
technology today the approach for
assassination there's so many different
ways to do it because you can Gaslight a
lot more today than you did before not
everybody watched the news back in the
days today everybody uses social media
which essentially forces everybody to
watch the news because if you watch
social media you're automatically
watching the news because you're being
fed whatever people want you so you know
we're 40 years ago enough 60 years ago
people are like I don't know if I need
to watch anything with politics I don't
need to listen to the news to do you're
forced to do it so they can't do what
they did back in the days but they're
going after this guy hardcore it's going
to be interesting to see what happens uh
uh the next six 12 24 months with the
situation of trump and what other
creative way they try to go after the
family and if someone's gonna break
and just say man I want to distance
myself from what's going on with my pops
versus unifying which will irritate the
hell out of them but I was just sitting
I was having a conversation with a
couple friends I said what do those two
families have in common because if you
think about the two most hated
families by the elite I don't know if
there's anybody that's above those two
families well the elites hated Reagan
too but maybe not the family Reagan
didn't have a real United like Iran Iran
his son turned against him Ron is a yeah
but the establishment couldn't stand
Ronald Reagan either so that was in
common they couldn't stand him yeah but
the family got thick and the most hated
family the Two by The Establishment and
the elites has got to be Kennedy and
Kennedy and uh Trump I wonder if it's
because they're kind of messy and by
messy I meet unpredictable meaning that
you know they're they don't they're not
they don't tow a predictable line you
know the anti-establishment thing goes
beyond just the establishment when I see
when we say the establishment oftentimes
we think of like the Republican
establishment of the democratic but also
the institutions as well as Tyler
mentioned I think once you're willing to
kind of
fire at the institutions that becomes
deeply threatening to the larger
establishments yeah and like messy yeah
and like especially like you know JFK's
biggest what what I've apparently killed
him going against you know saying no war
no Vietnam going against LBJ going
against LBJ finish Trump and I think we
talked about this Pat on one of the
first podcasts that I was on here uh
like I think like six months ago Donald
Trump the moment he was like I'm gonna
drain the swamp alligate when you drain
the swamp you think alligators snakes
they just go okay thank you they don't
go quietly they bite they come back they
attack and dude that's what it is and
the moment dude if you think about it
love them or hate them fake news just
think about that one you hear fake news
that woke up how many people so I'm not
gonna front that made me go wait a
minute CNN dude I listen to CNF I listen
to everything I just figure out you know
I figure out what the [ __ ] is I
figure it out myself dude that made CNN
like now look look at CNN because of
yeah fake news the gym Acosta now look
look at Sam people are are really waking
up and he did it and during the swamp
that was his biggest mistake talking
[ __ ] to the media because think about it
if you right now you go and you see uh
the White House Press briefing who's
who's the girl that's on there right now
uh the black girl yeah so think about it
she Peter Ducey is one guy he's the only
guy everybody else is quiet ask the
questions and then she shuts them out
she's like you don't know you don't you
don't know when uh uh who's uh Eric uh
Sanders was in uh what was her name
Sanders uh Huckabee Sanders it was 90
people yelling they were attacking her
and you know I mean this going after him
he's doing a great job he's the only one
that he's the only and the way he does
it is so phenomenal but he asked the
question and she's like so what do you
think about Jen sacky what she said
about crime being up and the fact that
the elections well I can't really talk
about it
but I will tell you I don't think that's
what she really meant but I disagree
with her on this it was so awkward and
what happened with it look to wrap it up
here a couple different things here's
what you need to know that we believe in
we believe the future is bright we're
very confident about the future being
bright because I fully believe the right
leaders are going to rise up there's a
couple things I do want to tell you guys
these hats finally came in these are
customized hats if you want to a little
bit with the camera I don't know if they
can do it from back though or not okay
so it's it's a it's a uh these will go
out in no time they've already I think
there's only like 120 of these left but
it's the valuetainment shield on the
front on the side it says future looks
bright right here and then on the lid It
also says the future looks bright with
the inside having valuetainment all over
it so if you haven't ordered one of
these we got them in Black we got them
in red we got them in Black uh uh white
and they will go very very quickly so if
you want to put the link below if you're
a value chainer if you followed a
podcast if you represent free enterprise
free market freedom of speech you're a
free thinker and you want to represent
that in the market go get yourself a
value team and hat put the link below
for people to be able to get this merch
we don't have a lot of these these will
sell out in no time uh so go look click
on the link below get your hats ordered
the future looks bright aside from that
minute for some of you guys I want to
get in contact with Jedediah and you
want to do a FaceTime with Jedi maybe
you heard the conversation today you're
like I love what jeded I was saying I'd
love to have a 15-minute conversation
with you you can have a 15 minute face
time with Jedediah
with Vinnie or with Adam or myself or
Tate or Kiyosaki or transparment or a
lot of different experts on minec the
app that just came out allows you to
connect with people that you ask them
hey do you have a minute to connect I do
on minact and you pay by the minute to
connect with influencers and experts on
minute the app Tyler put the link below
as well for people to be able to
download the app uh it's so far the
fastest growing app in its space on
connecting with experts it's pretty much
a uh a cameo and only fans except with
influencers and experts okay so Adam's
not going to show his feet
joke with my shirt off so I'm in and by
the way Vinnie is shredded you may want
to see if anyone with that shirt off
probably the most in-shaped guy in the
office I haven't said that I didn't say
I wasn't going to show
equal opportunity
just flipped to only friends do we have
a podcast this week or not on Thursday
uh yeah hopefully fill it up on the
hurricane in mud I'm gonna be in La this
week I'm gonna be in La this week I've
got some stuff going on in L.A cannot
wait to be at the driven event with all
the guys in La so I'll see those if you
guys that are going there Saturday I
will see you there take care everybody
have a good one bye bye bye bye